the remoteness immediately hits you as
you arrive in the northern territories
in yellowknife a first nations welcome
was waiting from the detto community
it's been a tour where the prince has
wanted to listen and learn but the way
that indigenous people have been
mistreated has hung over the visit the
prince unexpectedly wanting to say more
on the issue
i want to acknowledge their suffering
and to say how much our hearts go out to
them and their families
all leaders
have shared with me the importance of
advancing reconciliation in canada
we must listen to the truth of the lived
experiences
of indigenous peoples
but for families like jonathan's it
still isn't the apology from the royals
that some have demanded
my parents my grandparents my aunt
uncles and a bunch of them that all went
to residential schools
they don't always share everything that
happened to them they don't share
everything that happened to
their friends or their cousins brothers
and sisters and
still scarred the community
so it happened to our parents and
grandparents but it's still affecting
us right now
we had thought the climate crisis and
the impact of warming temperatures on
ice roads was going to be the main focus
here but he's clearly been so moved by
what he's heard from indigenous leaders
over the last few days that rather than
just making a few remarks on the last
day of this tour he's wanted to make a
full-blown speech as canada is preparing
to mark the first anniversary of when
those remains were found of children
abused in residential schools
the final send-off was about celebrating
the queen and the jubilee but this has
been another royal tour where her son
has had to confront more difficult
issues
his willingness to meet and join in at
least seen by elders as a real sign of
respect from a man who wants to be a
credible future king
rhiannon mills sky news in yellowknife
in canada